[Music]
in mind
texting news sound effects you think so
fast but you can't keep up with your
mind all the time yeah wait like your
body can't keep up with your mind yeah
yeah that's the way I heard that that's
why people stutter because their brain
is too fast for like that makes sense
that's why I don't finish my sentences
cuz as I'm saying it I already wrapped
it up and I'm like I want you to ask
this question are you ever writing with
your hands now because the texts you're
thinking ahead of where your hand is so
you skip words oh because of texting
make made me fast right like like and I
can think about what I'm saying
but handwriting wise I can't be as quick
so I always skip words when I'm in pain
ready now that's cuz you done right but
I do the thing where I don't finish my
sentences cuz in my head I already
finished it yeah like I think everyone
got the end of my sentence already it's
like you get it right yeah yeah I'm like
so I moved on and I never and then I
watched the playback I'm like I didn't
even finish my any of my sentences and
you're cooking videos that's the worst
thing ever then he agrees that we have
starting sentences in my head I already
started it I'm gonna bring it up to
someone they're like what's going on you
know submitted by fake love fake love
isn't that most people's love yeah well
that's sad oh yeah we got the real the
real so we're special the first social
network of brains
let's three people transmit thoughts to
each other hmm I don't like it I don't
like people my thoughts me neither get
out of my hear their voice no I think
that whenever I read comments from
people like when david has his captions
I read it in David's voice I hear Davis
lecture II tone
every time I read surreal I've always
liked David his luxury meeting yeah see
the thing is the thing you need to know
though you really need to know though I
grew up with this kid period yeah shut
the [ __ ] up haha that's why all my
friends say they say you basically say
stuff like you tell you somebody shut
the [ __ ] up yeah yeah that's how they
describe it it's pretty accurate so this
story here they're talking about how
they have now been able a scientists
have been able to figure out how to have
three people communicate just only using
their brain wave and so this is kind of
what it looks like I want this know cuz
I immediately I like have Tourette's of
the mind if I know that people like are
hearing my thoughts Mike don't say [ __ ]
papa [ __ ] and then I just like you know
like don't talk about dicks and then
I'll just start I'll start think it's
like thinking the things that I'm trying
not to think about yeah cuz I can't have
that because people will actually know
what I think about them and it's
terrible right now it's still very
primitive it's just like signals so for
example here what they did is like
they're playing a tetris game and these
people here they can only see the top
half of the of the screen which will
then tell the bottom half person which
is this person how they should either
whether they should rotate the block or
leave it at it as it is as it's falling
down and then so these two people send a
signal to this person to tell them like
either rotate it or don't and so they're
pretty much playing Tetris like that
that's fun they really primitive right
now but imagine like how fast this
technology could grow they only tested
it with this group of people just like
these two people I'm not sure I just
know that they've been testing in that
they because some people are more
intuitive than other people that's true
too but they are loved they we're also
doing a different type of game where was
like a twenty questions type of game and
then like they have to figure out what
it is like they're just been do is just
it gets really scientific in the article
but it's just the whole point is that
they've been figuring out a way to
create like a social network of like
mine but I need to know that their
regular ASP LED people like not like
some people like in 11 and freaking that
show yeah that's strange stranger things
dirty did a similar study like this and
it's [ __ ] crazy how it
came out I might butcher this but
there's a imagine like study group a is
in Australia and study group B is in the
UK right and then and then let's say in
Australia they they show this group like
like a picture or like whatever and then
in the UK more people that are a part of
the study group can like recite the same
thing like men who stare at goats type
thing
I forgot them can I ask who there's like
that control group is it like hey you
guys we gave you a pill you now have
mental telepathy go ahead and then to
people like yeah but there's nothing
else like how do they test the [ __ ] yeah
I don't know oh well this one yeah they
use e what is it ee g's and transcranial
magnetic stimulation yeah of course so
it's like they're reading brainwaves in
the whole point they're reading the
brainwaves and through the brainwaves
they're sending these signals to the
these there's these flashing lights with
15 Hertz or 17 Hertz so it's like
different frequencies and then that's
how they're able to send those messages
through the frequencies of the
brainwaves like I said they get a really
this is something that already exists
like and we're just figuring out ways in
like medicine and science how to like
identify and create it because if you
think about like the ancient religions
and [ __ ] and like how they use
meditation and how they control their
brain frequency and all that stuff like
they've been trying to do [ __ ] like this
but it's not like like magic like it's
not like like to the extent of like
getting into people's minds and in them
getting into yours or like that [ __ ]
crazy but it's more like the difference
between when you are conscious and when
you're on autopilot so like for example
like if you practice mindfulness or
whatever then you want to control your
behavior you want to control your the
way that you're operating so then you
don't go on autopilot and sometimes you
don't act like yourself when you're on
autopilot right so when you're autopilot
you're just playing programs that
basically
picked up like habits like your parents
habits or whatever so when people go
like oh you're acting like your dad
and it's like what what do you mean
because they're on autopilot right so
they're not focusing on how they're
acting so they both yeah he went on
autopilot like Adam Sandler's click oh
yeah yeah maybe was sad yeah I did
deevak first of all I did too cuz that
should be sad did ya like when he was
like talking to his dad and then he's
like what is the greatest part of that
film though was in the rain scene where
he just reached up and he gave the
finger yeah oh no or in this one anyway
but yeah so this is pretty crazy well
the cool thing is is that I good since
growing up like from having no internet
to now worry Internet's everywhere like
I like used to click on Mouse's and P
boards on [ __ ] but now I just get so
lazy on my own when I click on another
thing you know I mean yeah this will
allow you to just think about it we
could get even lazier do my email
started doing that has Gmail do that to
you lately freaky like stop you don't
know me you don't know the end of my
sentence and you're like yeah you do
sometimes it's right and I'm like okay
the other one actually oh that was
because at the end of my team it always
says [ __ ] you buttons have you seen
those oh yeah yeah yeah they fill in
with like [ __ ] use no down for mine it's
like it's it's verbage that I use like
it will say like oh that's tight or
whatever like it'll say that yeah oh I
thought it was generic because I always
generic words like no problem maybe
you're a generic ass [ __ ]
you read my mind you would know that
because mine says like sure thing and
I've never said sure thing yes true well
they started more generic and then now
it's like whoa that's exactly what I was
gonna say do you think do you think it
knows where you're from like if you're
from Ohio it's like well he'll probably
have some pretty generic [ __ ] and then
it's like if you're from California
he'll of generic ship what he thinks
it's like really creative in advance but
it's just more generic well maybe if I
send that to the same person cuz like a
lot of the correspondence is with like
the same people and I used like kind of
similar responses so it's like oh when
she talks to this person she says this
does it kind of creeped you out yeah
just keep learning us I still fill it
out out of spite I'm like no let me do
it I don't like when things do things
yeah but then this time next year you'll
just be letting to do it and you'll love
it oh do you guys see the app that makes
calls for you and in books like yeah
Google is doing all of this [ __ ] that's
cool just tell them and in Google
assistant I don't think it was and they
used into nations that are like humans
so they'll go and they'll pause and
they'll use a beat and then they'll
sound like normal humans and so the
person picking up has no idea that next
they should have Google boyfriends like
we said not for you baby but like
there's a lot of single girl like a lot
of my friends are like I just wish I had
like an intelligent guy to talk to you
like just some interaction you know
that's like deep they just have like you
program what what kind of boyfriend
personality you want black mirrors like
happening in real life right and if it
gets if it gets really good it'll have a
little intellectual conversation with
you and then 20 minutes later it'll send
you a dick pic because it thinks that
who you were having a really sexual
perhaps but then I might be like that
movie her where he falls in love with
the the system and like it's not a real
person that's what she ends up in
advancing so crazy that like she leaves
him did you guys hear like remember when
Elon Musk went on Joe Rogan's podcast
and then he was talking about this exact
thing like he thinks that AI is already
the internet like we're programming the
Internet's no humans already like you
give me the
someone that's gonna take over I think
the internet I'll our collective
consciousness yeah so we are uploading
every fall I know is I'm going to be
dead so good luck Mike how do you know
David no David medical advances are so
advanced that you might live forever and
it could happen in three years dude we
don't know I'm going to be dead in two
okay I mean he was saying it to it I
forgot what it was I think those things
will be like you could just upload your
mind into like a cloud or some so they
just found out that we can up upload
information into our brains what yeah
bro I read about it like the matrix
yeah dude learning I know I bet you
anything we already do this right now we
already do this like when we die and our
soul attaches on to the frequency that
whatever you're vibrating on so so for
example let's say I'm an angry [ __ ] a
negative person right if I died at that
state and my soul vibrates at that
frequency and whoever is having a bad
day or depressed I could enter that
[ __ ]
I believe I am high right yep I think so
too
yeah and that's a collective cloud that
people upload their [ __ ] in when they
die like wait ghosts are on the cloud
now yeah you've always been the clouds
been there it's been there because if
people are like this they're like oh yo
what if what if AI takes over images you
know like that whole matrix thing right
where they just use your body and your
stuff who the [ __ ] cares i ignorant is
bliss yeah if I'm like locked up in this
machine they're just using my life force
and I'm like in this dream world I could
do whatever I want yeah he's like I
[ __ ] love the state man ignorance is
bliss I agree right dude I'm in ready
player one driving in Lorient talking
[ __ ] to all my friends while the world
is a dystopian nightmare wasteland
around me isn't that even better when
you do no but then now you made a
negotiation and in that imaginary world
now you're like the bobble you have all
this day yeah
selling out all humanity and [ __ ] no I'm
already little one love humanity's in
the world they're uploaded with you I
just want a world where I can look at
somebody and just tell them I don't talk
to them anymore you can't do that how
it's tough but you can do it I do it all
the time I'm not very agreeable we're
gonna get to the point where we be like
man remember before all the AI took over
our bodies and what a machine what if we
are a simulation that's creating a
second simulation so our AI we already
we already are the AI and we're creating
another one an old theory already right
well if I'm a simulation [ __ ] my
programmer then because I fractured all
my ankles but humor dislocating my [ __ ]
he's like I just take apart my player
just stopped him from having a good time
does he need his right angle and his
shoulder dude he's going to Hawaii and I
programmed a storm in there happy with
what this guy has been saving up his
whole life have a Tesla two semi-trucks
are gonna hit it like [ __ ] this guy huh
you shouldn't talk to him dammit he's
supposed to take all your camera
equipment again another way like you
what you would do if you had a sim
that's what I did to my sims
I said Sims were the saddest Sims of all
of all simulation that's true
[Music]